嘿 大家好 我们今天来聊一个我觉得是所有交易者都想知道的问题
那些顶尖的专业交易员 他们脑子里到底在想什么
他们跟我们一般人思考的方式到底哪里不一样
你可能会觉得 啊 一定是策略特别厉害吧
但答案可能会让你有点意外哦
关键其实不在策略 而是一种更深层的东西叫做心态
好 我们就一起来揭开这个秘密吧
好那我们就先来问一个最直接
可能也是最痛的问题
你是不是也想过
为什么为什么这么多人在市场里
最后都是赔钱收场
这真的不只是一个冷冰冰的统计数字而已
对吧
这根本就是我们
或者说你想要成为专业交易员
必须要跨过去的第一个
也是最大的一个坎
你想想看
每次我们一赔钱
第一个反应是什么
是不是马上就觉得
哎呀是不是我的策略烂掉了
我是不是该去找一个更神的指标
对不对
我们很自然的就会往外面找原因
但这就是好玩的地方了
真正的问题核心
其实根本就不在那些技术性的东西上面
那答案到底是什么
就是这个你的心态
没错
就是这个你看不到摸不着的内在因素
它才真正决定了你在交易这条路上
是成功还是失败
好那我们就正式进入第一部分来看看
为什么大多数人会失败
很多人赔钱了都会怪市场
说这个市场太难搞了
太不可预测了
但真正的关键
可能跟你想的完全相反
问题根本不在市场
而是在我们自己身上
那个我们很难克服的人性
你来看看这些情况
是不是觉得有点熟悉
比方说因为嗨卡错过行情
或是太贪心就冲动下单
或是眼睁睁看着
那亏损的数字越变越大
但你就是按不下
那个停损的按钮
还有赚钱的单子
赚一点点就急着跑
结果亏钱的单子
你却死抱着不放
让他赔掉更多
甚至明明进场前都计划好了
结果交易一开始
就自己乱改规则
这些全都是交易失败的经典剧本
你看问题是不是都出在
我们内心的挣扎
跟市场本身
其实没什么关系OK 既然我们都知道问题是出在自己的人性上了那下一个问题就是那些专业的trader是怎么克服的这就要讲到一个心态上
可以说是一个180度的大转变了
他们从来不想当什么市场的预言家
他们要做的是市场的应对者
记住这个核心非常重要
是应对而不是预测
你看哦
这两边的差别真的天差地远
业余的交易者
也就是以前的我们可能都是这样
满脑子想的都是预测
下一秒会涨还是会跌
然后呢
就会很执着于
每一笔交易都必须要对
结果就是
整天追着市场的各种小波动跑
把自己搞得筋疲力尽
但专业的呢
他们完全相反
他们只专注在应对
现在发生的事
他们的目标根本就不是
要百分之百的胜率
谁做得到啊
他们的目标是
确保赚的时候能赚到一大波
赔的时候只赔一点点
而他们手里最强大的武器
就是知道什么时候该等待
什么时候该不动
这句话
我真的觉得把交易的精髓都讲完了
交易最难的部分
是什么都不做
真的
就是这么简单
当市场的状况不明朗
没有给你清楚的讯号时
你能不能管住你自己的手
就是这份纪律
这份耐心
才是真正把高手
跟一般人分开的那条线
好 心态我们调整好了
也知道要等待了
那问题来了
我们到底在等什么东西啊
这就带我们进到第三个部分了
我们要等的是你真正的结构型优势
搞懂了这个
你才能够真正摆脱那种
一天到晚找神奇指标的迷思
去理解一个策略
到底为什么会有效
在我们继续之前
有一件事我必须先讲清楚
而且可能有点刺耳
市场上根本就没有
所谓的圣杯策略
真的没有那种
可以让你躺着赚
永远有效的完美方法
如果你到现在
还在找那个圣杯
那这很可能就是
你一直没办法
稳定赚钱的原因
所以如果没有圣杯
那那些pro到底在看什么
他们在找的就是这个
叫做结构性优势
这个词听起来好像很学术很复杂对不对但你先别怕它的核心概念其实很简单就是在真实世界里造成价格波动的那个供需不平衡
所以重点已经不是图表上那些线怎么画了
而是你要去理解这些线条的背后到底发生了什么为什么的故事
所以你看一个专业的交易员在他要按下那个下单钮之前
他脑子里跑过的流程是像这样子的
第一步他会问自己
为什么价格会在这里动
他不会就只是看线
接着第二步他会去分析
现在市场上是谁在买又是谁在卖
有没有人是被嘎空或断头
被迫出场的
最后一步他才会判断
好综合以上这些
这里有没有一个很明显的供需不平衡
可以让我占到便宜
你看这才是真正有深度的策略思考
那讲了这么多
我们到底实际上要看什么
很简单
你只要记住几个重点
第一
市场的真相
永远都藏在价格跟成交量里面
这两个东西不会骗人
第二
那些新闻啊
热门故事啊
他们顶多就只是个催化剂
点火用的而已
你的焦点应该要放在
市场本身的结构
而不是那些新闻标题
最后一点
你一定要搞清楚
你的对手是谁
你是在跟法人玩
跟大户玩
还是跟跟你我一样的散户在对赌
好
到这边我们有了对的心态
也知道策略要看什么方向了
但是还缺了最关键的一块拼图
少了它
你前面做的再好都没用
你根本活无下去
这就是第四部分
风险管理
我得强调一下
这不是什么建议而已
这是这个游戏里面
完全没有任何妥协空间的生存铁则
这句话
我希望你把它牢牢记在心里
它可能会完全改变你对赔钱这件事的看法
停损它不是你失败的证明
它就只是一笔生意上的成本
你想想看
你开一间店
要不要付房租付水电
那就是成本嘛
停损就是一样的道理
它是你做交易这门生意的必要开销
当你真的这样想的时候
你就不会再害怕停损
也不会觉得停损很丢脸了
接下来这个真的超级无敌重要
就是你部位大小的力量
你想一个情况
如果你部位下的不对
就算你看对方向了可能也只赚到一点点便当钱但只要你你看错一次,哇,那个亏损可能是毁灭性的,直接毕业。但反过来,如果你部位控得好,你看对的时候,那个获利是有感的,
你看错的时候呢,那个亏损也只是皮肉伤,完全在你控制范围内。
所以你发现了吗?最后决定你能不能活下来的,
常常不是你多会预测,而是你怎么管理你的部位。
所以说到底
我们做交易的真正目标是什么
不是要重乐透
不是要一夜致富
记住
我们真正追求的是长期的稳定
因为你知道吗
那种很惊然的长期绩效
其实都是靠复利滚出来的
而复利这个魔法
要能够发挥作用
只有一个前提
就是你的绩效要够稳定
没有稳定
你赚再多
都可能一辞就赔光
那都是假的
好
我们终于来到最后一部分了
讲了这么多
那到底要怎么走上这一条通往稳定的道路呢
我想先提醒大家
这是一趟旅程
它没有所谓的终点
而是一条不断精进的路
不管你现在是哪个阶段的交易者
其实都有不同的功课要做
如果你是新手
拜托
你先不要想着要赚大钱
你的第一个也是最重要的任务
是先学会不要赔大钱
然后乖乖的开始写你的交易日志
把每一笔都记录下来
那如果你已经是有经验的交易者了
这时候你该检讨的已经不是市场了
而是你自己的交易行为
从你的记录里面去找出那个最适合你
让你最稳定的交易模式
然后呢
就把它练到变成你的肌肉记忆
最后我想跟大家分享一个
可能有点残酷
但却是百分之百的实话
交易这条路真的不是那种
只要努力就一定会成功的地方
很多人真的花了超多时间
超努力在研究
但如果一开始的方向就错了
你越努力
可能只是让你赔钱的速度越快而已
所以今天讲了这么多
我想用这最后一句话来做个总结
他也点出了交易的最终核心
你能走多远
不取决于你多聪明
而是取决于
你能不能遵守你自己定下的规则
你看
这把成功的钥匙
到头来还是握在我们自己手上
那么问题来了
你准备好开始遵守规则了吗